money
art the future i want to understand it
all and what better way than the nexus
of all those things nft nyc 2022 that's
right ladies and gentlemen home of the
most single men in one place since joker
hit the big screens this event packs
more undeserved wealth in it than the
panama papers you just kind of have
random dudes walking around with jpegs
worth of house and speaking of houses i
haven't heard so much of the word
utility without any utilities since the
texas freeze hit my house last year and
yes those are some cheesy jokes and
maybe some of you think i should leave
it to the professionals but just
remember sometimes that professional
is amy schumer i don't know what nft
stands for i'm assuming it's looking out
not [ __ ] tonight is that
is that correct do i have that right
i mean yikes imagine paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a board ape
just to get caught a virgin at your
biggest event of the year and believe it
or not this is actually as good as it
gets ape fest was without a doubt the
biggest part of nft nyc and that's
really what all of it was about
basically the parties whoever had the
biggest nft projects got the biggest
stars and the only way you could get
into these parties was holding the nft
token so finally holding on to your nft
actually has value and depending on what
project you were at this paid off in
different ways if you were at a
mid-level party like doodles you'd have
people like pharrell but if you were at
the big boys ape fest you got a-list
celebrities we're talking eminem and
snoop dogg performances and then of
course going down the list you also had
more low tier more budget nft operations
with more budget celebrities people like
this dupe snob that's right ladies and
gentlemen this lady thinks she's getting
a picture with none other than jyn and
juice and actually she's getting a
picture with juice and gin
i mean that's got to sting after you
post that to instagram this is the
tactics of some of the lesser nft
projects who couldn't afford some of the
bigger stars and so they hired people
like this uh snoop dogg impersonator to
drum up excitement for their projects
and you know what it got me thinking is
that what nfts are all about are they
just the status symbol are nfts just a
litmus test for how rich you really are
and if so who's going to care about them
besides rich people it made me think
that the number one challenge for nfts
at events like this is really just
convincing the rest of us the poor's why
should we take these digital jpegs
seriously when most of them are designed
to price us out
and i have to say so far the sales pitch
on these things
isn't going well as this reporter showed
get your nfg's here get your nfts go
cheap park price price anyone get your
enerties now don't be shy
when the man with the bargains has
passed you by nfts anyone
anyone
nobody cares nobody seems to like nfts
we didn't find anybody who actually had
anything positive to say about them that
doesn't mean they're not here but just
goes to show what a crazy minority
people who like these things are now
it's true that nft enthusiasts may blame
the lack of widespread acceptance on
many things for example some of them may
just say they're early and nobody gets
it yet maybe it's just all the really
cringy moments nftnyc produced that i
haven't even mentioned yet things like
this i'm getting drunk on truth it's
truth and freedom
[Music]
[Laughter]
and look maybe you're thinking that's
not so bad maybe it's all these haters
of nfts that are the real problems
but all in all i don't think it's any of
those things i think the biggest problem
facing nfts is actually not the cringe
not the haters it's that right now the
purpose of a lot of these projects
is very vague i mean beyond the whole
like set it as your identity and wait
for the dollar sign to go up
it's not really clear why you would buy
one of these things maybe for now you
could argue that it's these all-access
parties that make it worth it but i
don't know if that's really going to cut
it because there are cheaper ways to see
snoop dogg than spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars and i think that's
why you saw a lot of these nft projects
this year promising to do a bunch of
things outside of nfts like doodles for
example announced it would be in the
music gaming animation consumer product
space all at the same time for some
reason meanwhile a competitor cool cats
is planning to launch a video game so is
board api club by the way but all of
this just kind of feels like these
projects admitting that their nfts
aren't really going to cut it justifying
those big price tags
and if they're not if the nfts aren't
the important thing
then what is
it's very hard to understand and nft
2022 didn't exactly help but then again
there's always next year how much have
you invested in nft so far to be honest
over six figures